the jurogan experience dude what do you
think about johnny bones coming back
so what do you think about this
because this is exciting this is
interesting right it's taking a long
time it's taking a long time but now
he's 253 pounds yeah big boy it is a
rock face look meaty now giant huge and
you know his jeans look at him yeah his
brothers are awesome look at him look at
him and his iq is insane off the charts
his [ __ ] iq the highest fight iq
maybe ever right up there with mighty
michael joe he always renege on me
he doesn't let you film him no it's just
it's never been a no
what has it been it's just been uh
we gonna work we're gonna work
i would listen i just did a 30 minute
film on sean o'malley i spent one day
with him
i told sean i'm gonna come to phoenix
from vegas i need you to do a lot of
[ __ ] in one day i flew in in the morning
left at 8 00 pm
that's like wilder if you give me one
day with a [ __ ] fighter i'm gonna
give you some hbo production [ __ ]
one person editing it shooting it and
that's all i ask for i don't need a week
with jon jones give me one day john's
interesting
shooting [ __ ] whoever breaks into john's
house is [ __ ] oh yeah first of all
he's got that he'll kill you he'll kill
you he'll kill you also he's got that
[ __ ] dog he's got a belgian malmo
that is like very trained like as
trained as they get like that dog those
are little raptors those are the dogs
they use overseas those dogs man you
cannot have that dog to be like a
regular person and just like leave it in
the yard that dog is going to jump
this [ __ ] so misunderstood i i
gotta get tap into his brain i just know
how to pull that out of people what john
is is the type of guy that does the type
of [ __ ] that john does like when you
open up a fight when you're the youngest
ever guy fighting for the title and you
open up a fight with shogun with a
flying knee that's a wild man he's a
wild man
you know i had a conversation with john
when all the [ __ ] was going down with
him and i said listen dude you're all
why i called him up i'm like you are a
wild [ __ ] and i go and that's
the type of guy that becomes the
greatest of all time you don't get to be
the greatest of all time just being a
normal person and i go and that's just
how that's just who you are you know i
know you made mistakes and i know you've
done stupid [ __ ] but you're still the
greatest [ __ ] of all time and
you could show the world bounce back
from this and show the world he
i don't know what it is it's like he
constantly like
the fans get on him because he always
posts his comparisons against khabib
like i had more title fights than he had
fights
jon jones you are the goat
khabib called his father said you're a
gift from god
pull up that quote from abdul monap
about john jones he is a gift from god
khabib ain't trying to compare to you
right like so you don't need to keep
trying to validate yourself it's us i
know but that's what i'm saying
he's getting trolled yeah because he
gotta validate himself like bro you
don't need to validate yourself so i
think it's just because he hasn't fought
in a while
and also because out of sight out of
mind yeah yeah there's that and also
because
you know when you've had all these
setbacks that those those things haunt
you doubt
you know all the [ __ ] that happened with
him all the terrible [ __ ]
all that stuff [ __ ] with him it's gotta
[ __ ] with him i just i just pray that
somebody
if john is listening to me i hope he has
a camera crew just documenting it at all
because you can't get this [ __ ] back
that's why i love documentaries more
than anything he doesn't need a camera
girl he needs you he needs you to go do
it because the regular camera crew is
not going to capture it all the way and
then he's not going to trust him right
exactly and he's not going to vibe with
them he's not going to have fun with
them and also you will know what to
capture you have a vision of like how to
put it together
i i the film is already done
in your head oh my god it is already
done come on jon jones it's already done
like one i promise you if i spent one
day with jon jones it would be let's
make it happen
i bet we can make it happen one day give
me one [ __ ] but he doesn't have a
fight lined up unfortunately that's the
best time to get the stories my most
popular [ __ ] is the dagger stand
chronicles
40 something million views right
that was khabib doing ramadan had
nothing to do with the fight right like
people love seeing these guys out of the
element yeah the same one when i just
deal with o'malley he talked o'malley
talking about how he owned property and
this and that and it's like i'm not bill
if you go look at anything i've ever
done i'm not having a fighter talk [ __ ]
about the opponent right i'm telling the
story about the fighter right i don't
give a [ __ ] about
uh trash talk i'm not getting no money
from the pay-per-views right so i need
to just tell the story about you as a
person if you go look at those youtube
comments
it's so many people just like i was not
a fan of this guy until i saw this video
yeah and that's if i saw one comment
that's all i cared about that's that was
the effect that i wanted like somebody
saw something different in sean o'malley
than hanging out with six nine and jake
paul and logan paul are the milk boys
right it's like i showed him as a person
his mom his dad like think about that
bro
he gave me access to his family his ch
his child his his his partner his mom
his dad his coach like these fighters
give me that type of access they got to
trust you enough to tell you the story
because now so many videographers out
there a part of this sport and they're
just putting music on video it's like
tell a [ __ ] story yeah stop just
putting rap music with a song like with
some footage and thinking it's cool yeah
it's cool for instagram but is that
gonna matter years later i still get
comments from on videos from four years
ago because
it lasts how is john 35 now how's john
now
he got to be young
well he's fairly young kamal is 36.
john's 35 yeah which is prime for a
heavyweight
that's right that's good i mean glover
is the champ what is the champ well
light heavyweight light heavy 42.
um but
glover no francis is what 37 yeah
francis is like at least 37. so john is
younger than francis yes
yeah stephen he's in his 40s right steve
is 41
dc retired at what 42
yeah something like that